I'm again the musician so no idea about
education i went to the dictionary so
education about actually so wonderful my
open up the dictionary and the at the
definition of education and in an
official English fees oras is the action
of teaching somebody something in a
school so I'm not joking I turn the page
looking for that bit where it continues
and that and that and that will the next
page had something else so that is the
official definition in the English
language of what education is about is
the act of teaching somebody's stuff in
a building so I realize we have a
problem then I started thinking about
that and I realized that in a sense
that's exactly what it has become so
anyway I'm repeating what Rob said
before but this is exactly the situation
so I started thinking about that and end
up writing this little survey which I
will summarize I promise of the past few
decades and what's been going on with
what we used to consider education which
is now become a farce in many ways but
so in the 60s we had this wonderful
situation where we wanted to take
education away from those evil elitist
people that you know where you could
only be educated if you're rich or noble
or something like that and make it
available to everybody and edit few
other slogans to that so education for
everybody and all that and we thought
it's going to lead us somewhere
absolutely wonderful well it's led us
absolutely nowhere and elitism in every
possible way became like a swear word
it's like oh if your elitist you are you
know you're right wing and you're a
capitalist and you're here and you're
there and you know the privileged
everything which was about the
privileged people became some sort of a
swear word which is an interesting
movement I mean of course many many
things in that notion are very very
important that they have happened but it
also led us to a situation where we have
trained people over the past 40 years i
would say in a completely completely
destructive way so if a shin has to be
reachable to everybody then it means
everybody should be able to a get a
degree be finish a degree then get a job
in it so since anything which is
remotely connected to the world talent
or sensitivity or disposition
is of course evil because it's elitist
then we have to find a different way of
making sure everybody can be trained so
if they're not if their sensitivities
cannot be approached then we have to
find something that is the same for
everybody it's all about being the same
for everybody now so what's the same for
everybody stuff that you can measure
stuff that you can count stuff that you
can define so we defy we've found
wonderful ways to train people with
these tools if you do follow this and
descenders in this rule and you listen
listen listen than that even if you have
absolutely no talent for this specific
job or notion or direction you'll be
fine you'll never be very good but you
be all right but it's not about being
very good because that's elitist so just
be all right now so we became
extraordinarily good in being mediocre
and that became the comedy nominated to
everybody let's find a way to make sure
the whole of society is mediocre so
nobody gets too good so they're not
elitist only those that understand the
system and manipulated and so then we
had this wonderful system developing of
training people through measurable and
definable criteria to make sure they
have the widest common denominator
possible which is mediocracy now since
we have this huge mass of people that
now all have a degree we all have to
give them jobs somehow knows what do
people do they start specializing
because there is no time anymore to
actually be curious about anything
because you have to you know only living
and you've got the four hundred billion
other people that have just finished
Business School so you have to be you
have to specialize in something so you
mentioned this wonderful term the
Renaissance man has died with a student
revolution basically because we don't
have time to read anymore we don't have
time to be interested in anything that
is not directly and practically give us
something useful so don't read don't go
to the theatre don't travel it's
completely useless you will not make
more money if you travel and definitely
be interested in anything just go pick
up one tiny niche of whatever it is it
is your job specialize in that niche as
well as you possibly can till the point
that you do it better than anybody else
and that is the key to success
and what is success success is as this
great thing that we have been
brainwashed to seek for so long you know
it's it's money and its possessions its
power and its position and all those
things that we can never really reach
because the more we have over the more
we want of it it's a wonderful system by
the way I mean it works perfectly making
people go on working and working working
than die so it's a part of exactly that
same thing so specialized specialized
specialized get absolutely nowhere with
it now I have to tell it's tiny little
anecdote which I put in my essay I
promise it's not going to get that long
i'm getting to the point now so it's
it's a bit this is briefly is about
music there was in the 1980s a professor
of piano and the university of indiana
which used to be very important school
for from music now it's a bit of a
factory but it used to be anyway who one
day decided to change the little sign on
his room which used to say professor of
piano because everybody became professor
of early music professor of electronic
computer blah blah blah professor of how
to turn a chair from blue into red so he
just decided to write professor of music
then nobody noticed except one guy who
told me the story 30 is later and I
think this man was incredibly innovative
and incredibly sensitive and worried he
has been long dead now maybe better for
him because if he saw what's become of
music he'd be very very very very sad to
realize that there is no such thing as a
professor of piano or professor of how
to turn this class and well yeah it's
it's we are I mean musicians we are
artists where members of society where
members of a larger culture were members
of a large array of different cultures
now point number two which is a result
of this whole specialist movement i
called my essay by the way the age of
specialist it's just just one part of it
part number two is let's say 50 60 70 80
years ago varies in different fields
people use to define themselves through
belonging to a collective of some sort
it used to be countries and religions we
realize that's a really bad idea about
80 or 70 years ago so we stopped doing
that so we decided to find something
to define ourselves through so we would
be part of a great company a part of a
great movement or a great party or some
sort of idea and then at some point the
more that people had access to education
and to now it's the internet and YouTube
and what all not all these things that
give people the chance to specialize so
well and people think ok now I can do
all these things I'm so good at this in
addition to that I'm not going to define
myself through belonging to this great
prestigious collective that is that you
know it's a great honor to be this
little element of a big collective it's
all about me I am so special and so
important so even in music if let's 100
years ago a violinist would not have a
greater dreams and to join a great
Orchestra because it was about the music
well no now I can you know I can I can
play better than everybody else because
now there is three billion people who
are incredibly mediocre so everybody
wants to be a soloist because it's all
about me and that through that develop
this and this is just a little Ellis
example of the sort of transformation
between collectivism to individualism
where it became all about this beautiful
word of self-fulfillment now before the
American right has decided that it's a
great day to make money by selling books
about that it still existed only that
many many years ago self-fulfillment was
something so natural and subtle in many
ways that people derived it from very
very small and very very beautiful
actions in their day-to-day life people
were happy if they could earn a living
if they were healthy if they had maybe a
family and we're very content with that
because it was there were part of this
cycle of culture and of society nowadays
it's how M I and my individual self
which is going from here all the way to
that wall can fulfill ourselves so we're
not fulfilled by being belonging to a
collective as we've established and we
were filled by being special so we came
into this wonderful era of being
everybody trying to stick out and be as
special as they can so if you have a
mass of specialists that are already
specializing one tiny thing and then it
suddenly be exactly the opposite started
happening you have to
distinguish yourself from this massive
specialist because there's so many of
them that if you want to be even be
noticed you have to be different so it's
not any more about being good or honest
or have any sort of substance it's just
about being different so you're
surrounded by this I mean we have here
somebody from the world of theater or
somebody em from the world music Heather
in every kind of art and actually you
have it in every kind of part of society
it's not any more about being good it's
about doing the most crazy [ __ ] just to
make sure that somebody notices you
right so funny enough it actually ended
up exactly where we started because
sticking out is just as elitist as where
we sort it out now it's only that it's
not anymore the you know nobility it's
not anymore the privileged rich and so
on and the well-born that have access to
education and to culture and so on now
it's all these extremely mediocre and
ignorant people that decided to turn
education to a money machine basically
that have act that have control over it
so we've replaces this with that but
we've gotten where exactly the same
place now sticking out is not elitist
anymore it's a trademark so it's a
wonderful way of making sure you will
not be forgotten yet another extremely
important goal to aspire to so what is
knowledge actually what is education I
mean we have I think we live in a time
that if people describe knowledge or see
knowledge as information so I want to
know something about something I go on
google or in Wikipedia and read the
first line and a half if I'm very
curious two lines and then I really
mastered the subject I've known all
about Leonardo by having read where he
was born way he died and that he painted
this one really famous painting what was
her name again well that one so that's
all you need to know you're done with
that subject so that's that's the same
symptom of this whole specialist thing
and I personally strongly believe that
knowledge is about an identity and it's
about a cultural identity to start with
and it's not about actual informations
about making connections between
different kinds of information between
different kinds of observations between
different kinds of experiences and I'm
going to finish all this with coming
back to
both of you have said we have educated
people over the past decades to know
more and more facts that make it more
and more possible for them to be very
successful in a specific field to a very
high degree of specialization so on what
it already described but we have
completely abandoned the notion of
making empowering people to become
humans which is for me first and
foremost the act of questioning we're
giving people masses and masses and
masses of facts and of information and
say this is the truth this is the truth
this is the truth you do this you get
there you do that you get here but I
think the only way to get anywhere is to
doubt we have to question all these
things that we know and make sure the
next moment that we are absolutely sure
we don't know anything at all then we
may be made one centimeter of progress
so if we ever go anywhere with this
whole act of individualism or what I
call pseudo individualism and turn that
into real individualism that would be
about learning how to question our own
identity question our knowledge and
maybe then make a tiny little bit of
progress but realizing how little we
know I know how much we know that's a
little bit for me thank you